on voit en effet retiré ses soirées gang
bang ok
je dis
non
imagine sa tête si je vous dis que ça
fait un an je fais ça c'est bon
ça fait un nom son jouet déroule
prochaine fois j'essaierai lui est là
[Musique]
or
des loges du prêtre lui incertain
un récit
genre de meuf est un mec dirait pas non
plus passer ça va pas être possible on a
arrêté toute relation sexuelle on a
découvert un plaisir qu'ils étaient
infectés dogues
passeur bonjour bon sens non
[Musique]
les merveilleux c'est un énorme malade
ma soeur est folle de toiles n'attend
qu'une chose c'est qu'elle épouse et tu
me fais une déclaration de merde non
mais j'hallucine non mais tu vas le
faire soigner à bien
quand même
je suis ok pour qu on se filme mais pas
pour me lancer dans le porno je suis pas
exigeant
d'accord on le fait mais que pour moi
jurerait mandat
oh
oui oh [__] oh [__]
[Musique]